I'm a Sarah Paulson I'm James McAvoy we
are doing a wired autocomplete interview
I really thought you got that right the
bird's eye view did an exam is Sarah
Paulson related to Lana Del Rey the
answer is no oh yeah someone has walked
up to me and asked me and they thought I
was pulling their leg tonight when I
said no we know what you obviously
thought you we're not what I was hurt
all I see is Sarah Paulson in Apocalypse
yes it's yes I am yes I was hey but yeah
I was on a TV show called American
Horror Story ha ha I was like I was in
Apocalypse is Sarah Paulson British I
know why they're doing this I know why
they Google this I did a really horrible
British accent on the show almost as a
spoof I was playing an actress on the
show who was like sometimes a movie and
I think it's a good nobody like this is
on Twitter they were like no this is not
a British accent and then I was getting
a lot of for it and so then people were
like we have to google it which means
some people were unsure so I'm gonna
take that as a compliment why is Sarah
Paulsen always crying in ahs hotel well
well it's a pretty terrifying terrifying
nice to be kiddies and cuz I was also
told - where is Sarah Paulsen from you
from Boise Idaho you're from Gibraltar
you're from from Toledo
you're from New York
Charleston oh you're from Disneyland
from Disney World
you're from Tampa Tampa is James McAvoy
left-handed
no it's James McAvoy in Game of Thrones
no no love to be though it's James
McAvoy from Port Glasgow thanks for
asking this no I'm not I'm from Glasgow
but is it a phone like if your front
port Glasgow you're not from this thing
and what the true separate place is just
like Port Glasgow is but it seemed like
it irritated you nah I'm just glad that
like most cleaners up I'm glad that you
who is James McAvoy's sister joy Maria
McEvoy yeah sorry
and two doors down she's great it's
James McAvoy and meaning if he's in it
I'll go see it
I yes I'm in it does Sara Poulsen have a
daughter who does Sarah Paulson look
like Sarah Paulson thank you does Sarah
Paulson have an Oscar
oh no no turn the club baby you deserve
one I vote for you you don't I did I put
you in the number one slot and
everything you everyone says you're
supposed to do that it gives you like
it's more weight I don't understand it
but someone told me that and I put is
Mary list James McAvoy number one for
split does Sarah Paulson sing no I did
sing once in American Horror Story but I
had a coach and someone like in the
recording booth with me helping me
visually by going like this it was very
sad does Sarah Pope Sarah Paulson does
drew Barrymore impression
yes she does I think I've seen it your
turn does James McAvoy have an accent
here's the thing the only people who ask
that are American people they say oh do
you haven't you have an accent
I'm like so do you know that I don't
have an accent but no we all have an
accent
where I'm from your accent is American
Oh some American know those James McAvoy
has fat che Berg no I don't have
facebook does James McAvoy die in
Atonement I'm not telling you guys that
cuz that would be a spoiler in case
somebody's not washed those James McAvoy
speak French
no what song does James McAvoy dance to
in split can't flip and remember no it's
neither drink nor can you don't think in
in split alright
what is Sarah Paulsen's favorite color
I like a kind of eggplant color hate the
food love the color I mean I also love
it's my favorite emoji that eggplant
emoji it can stand in for a love thing
what does Sarah Paulsen eat I could I
say
what Sarah Paulson character are you
what Sarah Paulson character are you dr
myko about your posture just immediately
I just watched you in Bert books last
night and I'd like to be a horse lady a
horse lady on a ranch
I would actually that be a lovely life
what height is Sarah Paulsen I'm gonna
be here against this room five six whoa
yes they're actually in a he'll around
you so that takes a little extra special
hi james mcavoy how james mcavoy get
totally ripped yeah his name's Magnus
his name is Magnus leg back he is a
Viking from Sweden he looks like a
Viking and he's just very very good at
putting muscle on people real quick he's
just doing gal gadot and he just did Ben
Affleck and he did they've skarsgård boy
from Tarzan
eyes guy just thank you sorry I didn't
know his first name how did you mark
avoid get famous it's a little-known
story back to the middle
don't know really big thing back home
was a TV show called shameless which I
think we made here on Showtime
oh yes the gangers Gallaher's yeah so
maybe shameless back home was one of the
big things for me that catapulted me
right to the middle how many movies has
James McAvoy been in I don't know 30
something I think maybe something so
like you don't have what Sam has which
is like every movie he's been in 120
meters I mean it's also pretty amazing I
do want to have that I do have underwear
ever thrown back and surely with your
name like your mom sewed in them no just
my movies
oh is Sarah Paulson vegan I was for
about two years I am currently a
vegetarian I'm moving back towards the
dairy kids is Sarah Paulson related to
John Paulson I do not know who that is
so that's know if Sarah Paulson married
to Evan Peters I am buy back off is
Sarah Paulson Canadian sorry but I am
NOT is Sarah Paulson in suits how much
do they mean like seeing me in a suit
they might on the show you know sweet
shoes anyway nope nope no it's good
wars James McAvoy spider-man no
otherwise I didn't mistaken for tell
people I had a couple of times I'm gonna
talk we will go out be team right was
that James McAvoy in Deadpool - yeah
didn't really get paid for it good man I
didn't nicely we got like extra fees
that day at sporting artiste Wars James
McAvoy in Band of Brothers yes I was
very much what was James McAvoy's first
movie Oh a film called the near room
which is a reference to that Muhammad
Ali that was not the movie that catapult
you because I don't even know what that
I was 16 and it was a fella bit child
pornography and prostitution law school
and it was not a comedy thanks very much
you for your service
searches and your interest in Sarah
Paulson and James McAvoy